es ist der letzte tag des
weltwirtschaftsforums hier im schweizer
davos mit großer spannung erwartet wird
der auftritt des amerikanischen
präsidenten donald trump der schwebte
gestern schon hier in den schweizer
alpen ein und drauf anschließend einige
politiker zum abendessen empfing
donald trump dann die konzernchefs
verschiedene europäische unternehmen
darunter auch die vorstandsvorsitzenden
deutscher konzerne wie siemens sap oder
adidas merkel und macken haben hier in
dieser woche in europa vorgelegt sie
haben ein bekenntnis abgegeben zu freiem
handel und multilateraler politik nun
liegt der ball bei donald trump von ihm
wird angenommen dass er seine politik
des america first verteidigt deshalb für
seine steuerreform wirbt und für
investitionen in amerika aber wer weiß
vielleicht kommt alles auch ganz anders
seien sie live dabei auf fasnet ab 14
uhr